today we're talking about cloud spanner
ecosystem restoration and chrome browser
cloud management i'm carter morgan and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
cloud spanner is a fully managed
relational database with unlimited scale
strong consistency and up to five nines
of availability
to achieve the best performance
characteristics it's advisable to launch
your production application when spanner
is in a warm state with splits already
balanced across all of the server
resources
check out the blog for a step-by-step
resource
protecting the earth's ecosystem from
further degradation and improving
outcomes for the wildlife and
communities that rely on them needs to
be a focus for the next decade of
climate action but where do we start
head to the blog to learn more about how
restore is helping to solve for
knowledge gaps and accelerate
restoration with data
it and security teams have a lot on
their plate from supporting the
transition to new work environments to
preventing an increasing number of
security attacks and as more and more
work is done in the browser it's
important for it and security
professionals to look at the browser as
a critical piece of infrastructure to
keep their organization secure
chrome browser cloud management gives it
teams a simple and efficient way to
manage and secure their browser across
multiple operating systems off from the
cloud check out the link for examples
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link and if you have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud